all right well thank you very much
and it's always fun to talk about
what we do here in silicon valley
regarding solar energy
and i hope you will find some of our
lessons interesting
uh so first of all why are we talking
about solar um
it the the last half decade to a decade
has been really
an amazing story for solar energy and if
you just look at the growth in the
industry compared to some of the
conventional
sources of power you'll see that there
is overall 15 gigawatts
of new capacity that's been installed
over the last year
versus three gigawatts of new nuclear
power
so when you think about what energy
source
is growing in capacity clearly the
renewable energies
have been growing a lot faster than
conventional power
particularly some kinds of conventional
power so what this
has led to and this is what i personally
find so exciting about being in this
industry
is that it is already an 80 billion
dollar industry
that's going to be going to a trillion
dollars in 2013.
um this kind of a growth rate is over
the last decade is basically
um you know uh has been experienced in
silicon valley here
but not in the energy industry and so um
i have you know had the good fortune
of getting involved um around the 2006
time frame
and so that tremendous growth curve was
something that um
you know experiencing has been a great
experience and i would
hope that everybody gets a chance to be
part of such growth
no matter what the industry is
one of the reasons for the growth is
because if you look at the price
of solar modules it has dropped
dramatically as well
and we'll talk a lot about about
modules and production and many of the
topics that
you guys had submitted questions on
during the course of the discussion
um you are welcome to interrupt me with
questions if you'd like
and i will try if i haven't covered your
questions during the discussion during
the talk
i'll try to make sure to save some time
at the end to talk about them
specifically so before i get going on
the actual
presentation i thought i'd just spend a
few minutes a few moments on
who i am um and leslie gave
introduction um and but let me just kind
of
substantiate that a little bit more um i
do
i did start off at the other place
across the bay
um i was actually born and raised in
berkeley as well my dad's a professor
there my husband's professor here so we
are house divided
but when i when i graduated and i was
fortunate enough to work in an area like
nanotechnology
which was also a very growing
industry at the time i chose to not
contune academia
but go into industry and that
bifurcation as you find you're going to
have these
critical decisions at various points in
your life and so that bifurcation was
in um an important one um as i mentioned
my dad is in academia and he said
post-docs
are you know done but they're not really
a great
use of your time is what he had
guided me to and so he encouraged me to
explore industry
when i looked at options because the
natural thing to do after grad school is
just to go on get a post i can try to be
a professor somewhere
but but i had kind of inclinations of
business anyway
and so i went and found a
position applied materials applied is a
very
customer focused uh company so i went
from the world of research
and kind of big picture thinking to you
know having a paycheck that says this is
paid for by happy customers so it was
pretty dramatic
um fortunately for me my husband was at
stanford during the time and so i could
always escape away
we were living in marriage student
housing and you know here on campus i
could always escape away to academia
when i needed to
but but as i look back those those three
years i spent it applied were very
um foundational for understanding the
industry and in that case it was a
semiconductor equipment industry
um but having had um a taste of that
um i moved on to um to agilent labs
where
um i had the pleasure of meeting leslie
and worked more
in the r d environment so i kind of i
think i went extreme into industry and
then stepped back a little bit more
in towards r d and there i was fortunate
to work on a project
that's related to the printed circuit
board assembly industry so
i was able to both change positions as
well as
change industries and then i had the
opportunity to do my
do my startup nanotubes in the meanwhile
had become
very exciting there were a bunch of
different startups that had started that
had
been founded by professors that were
pursuing nanotech
as a application in the startup area and
so
a lot of venture funding was going
towards that i looked at what those
applications were but now having spent
a fair amount of time in industry i
realized that i think these are really
far-fetched and it's
it's going to be hard to productize so i
came up with a business plan and idea to
use carbon nanotubes for
electronics cooling and i felt that that
was a lower risk technology
compared to the others and it was a
great experience
and you know i think one of the things
that are special about silicon valley
and the reason we pay such
high prices for our living is that we've
got this
sandhill um and the venture industry
here
is actually quite supportive so it took
no effort to um to you know
to start digging into what it would take
to write a business plan
there's a whole network of
both social and academics and business
people who are always willing to help
and so i had the good fortune of
receiving five million dollars of
top tier vc money and i went ahead and
pursued
my idea hired top people that had
that i'd come across in my other
companies and
we actually took the technology to where
as far as we could go and then i
um as a founder and ceo of the company
decided that i would
um since we had taken it to where we
could but the market had changed
instead of continuing on and and you
know spending more of the vc
funding that i'd raised we'd only spent
about half of it and i actually
um you know told the board that we can't
pursue the same market that we're
planning on so we can either change
markets or we can shut down
and i gave them back their money they
gave me back my patents
we had you know not the exact outcome
that we had hoped to from the beginning
but
it's a high risk industry it's uh and so
people expect
these type of ends as well overall
though i would recommend it to people
if they have a passion for something
because it's a great way to be able to
pursue
what you would like to do and then it
was an opportunity to think okay as a
technologist you know you can solve a
lot of problems but what are problems
that people really care about
and so solar had become quite you know
had
developed substantially in the past year
since i'd left grad school
and so i had the opportunity to um have
actually tj rogers on my technical
advisory board for my startup
and so through him um i got to know sun
power
and when i entered sunpower was 400
people
by the time i left three years later it
was 4 000 people
so it was that experience of growth that
that was was great and
and then i had the opportunity to join a
startup and i felt again as a
technologist it's really nice
to pursue a technology and i'll tell you
about that
um in the coming slides
okay so um as you see from my background
i've got technology i've got
startup i've got business so this
presentation is going to cover all of
those we'll start with technology
a solar panel is about a square meter
depending on the efficiency it can give
you 100 to 200 watts
it's not that much more than a light
bulb but a lot bigger
and so from an energy generation
perspective
um it's it's pretty simple device um
especially when you compare it to a lot
of the complicated semiconductor
devices that are produced here in
silicon valley
basically light comes in creates an
electron hole pair
you've got electrodes on either side
that capture it
and you generate power now the issue
really is
that that
much of the power that you
so so so what you do for processing is
um
you try to enhance as much of the power
that um
that that that was received by your
device translates into electrical power
and and you do that by you know various
techniques of texturing
and and when you look at
the loss mechanisms unfortunately
the much of the energy does not
convert to electrical power and
and so solar cell design and
manufacturing it's all about reducing
loss
you can't really optimize um you know
you you it's so so it's kind of
it's it's you know you you will never
get 100
so you start off with in silicon it's
about 30
is the best you can do and um and you
basically just
start fighting are working with physics
to reduce your overall losses
some of the types of losses are that you
the electron hole
pairs recombine before they get a chance
to get to the electrodes
so the quality of the material that you
start off with is very important
another is the type of texturing that
you have so that you can try to
have multiple reflections and and keep
the light
inside the semi-connecting material as
much as long
as you can that is another place where
there's
quite a bit of loss so overall your
standard
cell design at this point is about 18
efficient and and you know it sounds
very marginal but in the in the silicon
world
um this this number started off at
around
12 percent and so the industry has made
substantial progress
but now they're really kind of at the um
at a tougher point
in in from a technology perspective for
road mapping and trying to get more and
more efficiency
the highest efficiency to date for
silicon is actually sun power
and the design came out of stanford here
dick swanson the founder of sun power
was a professor before he left and
founded
his company and he's a you know a
dedicated
solar enthusiast and he worked on many
many projects
um until he was able to really turn this
technology into
a mass production industrial scale
and there's some special things that
that sunpower does i mean
it gets the cell efficiency efficiency
to be as high as 22 percent
um the cost is really been a key so
overall the
you know the the device itself is not
that complicated um
and what has been a um
a challenge for the industry has been
really cost reduction
and i've kind of given a
idea of where the cost is and this is
predominantly for silicon of course
so a lot of it is actually in the
installation itself
and and over the years this is this has
been reduced substantially people have
gotten better at
you know designing a package
for solar they can be installed by
people who are not neces
don't need to be so specially trained to
do electrical installations um
and then of course a lot of the
materials that were used the racking etc
you know
smart simple simple things actually
have made a tremendous impact in the
industry um
the overall panel itself um i'm starting
from the
the i guess right left side right side
there
um the solar panel itself um glass is
expensive
the um the junction box all of those
things that you really you
absolutely have to have they
you know they've gotten they've reduced
as the volume has increased
but but that is
still a substantial overall cost for a
solar system
and then the cell this is where there's
a lot of design features like we just
reviewed
and if you look at the overall equation
for trying to reduce
the cost of solar if you can increase
the power that's generated then that's
highly beneficial because you've got
a you know bigger number in the
denominator to divide everything
um with so efficiency is a huge lever
and and you know as long as you can get
efficiency but not
increase the cost of the production
you're really going to
be in a better position and
and people you know continuously of all
the standard cell manufacturers also
they work very hard to
increase efficiency even like tenth of a
percent um because
it's such a big lever on the entire
value proposition
and then there's the starting material
itself this um is silicon
um and and you'll see in a
minute why um silicon is is
uh the dominant uh material in the solar
industry
right now um and i
if for those of you who maybe have
followed the industry um
for the last couple of years there was a
time where
the silicon used for solar
the prices became very high because
there was so much more demand
and the solar the silicon producers
never expected solar to grow so quickly
so now the solar industry uses much more
silicon than the semiconductor industry
does but before that obviously
you know that was the other way around
and so they they didn't anticipate this
production
or they didn't anticipate this this big
surge in growth and so
they didn't have the production capacity
um and so they could get away with like
ridiculous prices so there's a little
place where the module price actually
goes up because silicon became really
expensive
um but then a lot of capacity came
online and so now those prices have
dropped substantially which has enabled
the solar panel
and cost to drop substantially
okay so um the if you
kind of do an overview of technology
they it falls into two
big chunks crystalline and thin film um
crystalline
there is divided into silicon which can
be both monocrystalline and
multi-crystalline
and then also i want to make sure to
to include gallium arsenide even though
it's a very very very very small
amount in the market overall um
it's it's important um and it's used
predominantly in satellites and um
you know extraterrestrial applications
for solar
thin film um amorphous silicon is one of
the
one of the technologies there it can be
deposited on
a glass plate which is rigid but it can
also be deposited on flexible materials
which
turns out to be you know a
unique way of deploying solar and then
six you hear a lot about sigs
particularly in the valley we have had
dozens of solar startups that are
focused on
six technology um one of the six
technologists
actually uh mentioned to me that uh
the challenge in getting any of these to
any of these companies across the line
has been
that there's so many ways that you can
deposit things you can plate it you can
co-evaporate it you can sputter it do
all these different and so
there was a lot of effort put on all of
them rather than effort
put on you know consolidated effort put
on any one technique
to get this technology across the finish
line so um
but there's still work being done on it
and it works you know this is the
exciting thing about solar is that you
know you have a semi-connecting material
you shine light on it
you have a an appropriate you know
design you will get power
it's just the efficiency of it and um
and the cost of it that matter and then
cattell
um first solar is the main um
you know uh of this material
and they have done a fantastic job in
developing it developing the technology
for it
which took over a decade and then a
and deploying it in the marketplace um
very strong manufacturing team um that
goes along with this technology that's
led to its success and then also um
this is where my current company alte
devices comes into play
gallium arsenide is um is as i mentioned
another
um solar material
but what we've done is actually taken
this
this high efficiency semiconductor and
and designed a process by which it can
be
both a crystal and a thin film so i'll
pass around some samples in fact
and then dot you can see from a market
perspective if you look on roofs around
the world
you'll see a lot more of the crystalline
than you will of the thin film
okay um speaking of roofs the
main area for application has been
uh rooftops uh for
residential applications which we call
distributed generation
um power plants um which
actually was one of the reasons for the
boom in the industry and where you
where people um the the incentives that
governments
put in place to to um to
establish um and develop power plants is
what caused this big boom in the
industry
and and then commercial buildings as
well where you've got large
air flat areas where you can deploy
solar modules and then um
i would like to add to this application
picture the what we like to talk about
as portable
and as i mentioned some of the thin film
technologies can be deposited on
flexible substrates
so more recently it's a niche market
at this point but but it's an emerging
market
of portable solar
so what i'd like to do now is kind of
segue and i have
quite a few slides that talk about alta
devices
which is where i work right now in fact
let me
while i'm talking i can pass around some
of the samples
we're a true silicon valley startup
and the the technology has come
out of here we go ken has come out of
caltech and uc berkeley and
we have a silicon valley team
that has spent the last five six years
developing this technology
and what we're trying to do
is basically um cut the cord
so we kind of think about power as
something that comes from a wall that
has to be translated
through wires and
wouldn't it be nice if we could change
that paradigm
and what it takes in our view to change
that is
you need to have a high efficiency you
need to have flexibility you need to
have light weight
and and with that
you can potentially make this type of a
mobile power revolution occur
so for towards that end we um
have developed a cell design that is the
world record actually 28.8 percent
um and um in for single junction
we for our dual junction is 30.8
and our overall module that would
that is 24.1 percent all of these have
been validated
by nrel in colorado the national
renewable
energy lab and and we can
certainly break our module record um we
used uh
you know just some standard cells um but
um but our focus right now is actually
to commercialize
the technology and so we've taken
the the the development that we did and
are now
moving into the phase of deployment into
applications so you know if you think
about
where you use power you don't just use
power sitting in your house you actually
use
power on the go and as
happens often with many applications
that are new
the the military is
a early adopter of new technologies
that have had the vision passion to try
to contribute to
to renewables and
and i wanted to kind of take this
opportunity to
maybe just go through what is the
pathway yeah
they've got it i think they've got it
what is the pathway for
a new technology an idea and innovation
that
that you know a person or a group of
people have
and how does it kind of life cycle its
way towards
commercial scale so initially um
it starts off with research often in a
university
um sometimes in a government um or an
industry
um uh you know lab
and then you've got an incubation period
we call this kind of the pre-commercial
gap sometimes ideas if people are not
depending on how well their champion
they either
get through this gap or not um
their angel investors play a role we
just over lunch had a discussion with
somebody who's
who's out there has a really interesting
idea combining you know
energy and gaming and you know angel
investors here play
an important role the vc industry also
depending on how much money you're
raising so
in my case i was here and i raised about
five million dollars because i needed
equipment i mean this was
this was hardware this is not just kind
of a software idea that i didn't you
know i would be able to get away with
smaller amounts of funding
um so so this is a this is where i think
you know having a champion
or somebody who cares deeply about the
idea
either crosses this valley or a lot of
ideas actually just never make it across
they're kind of a concept but then
people get busy with their
daily lives or if they're you know
whatever else they're they're involved
with
and um and lose the focus uh then you've
got
where you establish a pilot line and
this is um this is basically what we've
been doing for the last um
you know uh two years and um and the
venture community
plays a very important role um industry
and you saw
our the range of investors that we had
so a combination of industry and
nvcs help this phase
you know substantially then what happens
is you need a lot more money to
especially if you're
a hardware company um like us and like
most of the solar plays over here in the
valley
you need a lot more money to get across
so that you can actually
enter the market and then once you've
come once you have got across there's a
lot of money you know banks will give
you money
the government will give you money
industry will again come
in and play an important role but
getting past here is where
many of the solar startups have um have
been
um uh
have basically gotten challenged i know
several of you asked the questions you
know what's been what's led to
you know some of the um i guess quote
failures
um or the
the full cycle not being realized and
you know i think many people will have
their own
um views on it um for me personally
i feel that the venture industry played
you know as you see in this the venture
i mean the you know um
the vcs play an important role um
and in solar too they did a um
uh they did invest it's not that the
valley
did not actually take clean tech
seriously i mean you
they over you know the last decade
there's
over 6 billion dollars that have gone
into
clean tech but recently you see it's
gotten
much lower and the main reason for that
is that this money
poured in but the return
didn't come and so from a timeline
perspective
the vcs have not really
been able to satisfy their formulas for
returns
and so as they look at continuing
funding this effort
they see that they're not it's it's not
really fitting
the equation that they normally would
want to and the main reason
is um for solar is that um it takes
quite a lot of capital
and so the problem that happened or you
know the the timing for a lot of the
solar startups locally
is as they got out of pilot scale and a
lot of them very successfully developed
the technology you know many of the
companies that
are listed here did a great job of
taking their technology to
the lim to to where it could go in a
pilot manufacturing scale
and all of them had manufacturing in the
bay area
so the um you know the challenge was
really to kind of
get over now and do large-scale
manufacturing some chose to do it
here in um in the u.s most did not
choose to do in california it had to go
outside this state
but but and then you know
that activity takes quite a lot of
capital
um there and you know um
uh and i've kind of put a little
comment there as to what the current
status is and unfortunately we have had
some
publicly you know
discussed failures and so that's where
the industry has gotten a little bit
of its reputation that money has gone
in and return has not happened but it's
because more money
is required for return to occur so at
the same time as you need more money the
capital markets dried up
and everybody you know just from the
overall financial crisis
and then on the other side the um the
module prices dropped substantially so i
have a few slides that i'll talk to you
about that too and
what that dynamic has been like but so
you had
a very challenging market you had very
limited capital
and you had technology that hadn't
proven itself yet
and so that becomes very very you know
difficult
um to survive that situation and uh and
unfortunately many
you know very good companies with a lot
of passion and hard work that
went into them um were had to be asset
sailed
and so some are still around and we're
we're surviving to
um to you know either outlast the
capital
um drought
and in some cases people have been
gotten acquired by other companies that
are willing to put more capital into it
to grow um but that's basically
um you know the the current story
but um what
many of those companies were hoping for
was more of the first solar and sun
power story
so these are the u.s companies that um
had been
started much earlier like i said over a
decade ago i think
you know dick spent about 20 years
developing the sunpower technology until
he commercialized it
and in first solar also over a decade
they spent developing the technology and
they were both of these companies were
supported by
projects as well as you know
industry and corporate partners
so back in 2009
first solar was actually the um top
producer of solar panels
so even though thin film is is a smaller
amount of the overall market
they have substantial production
capacity and
they were a large producer
sun power has remained in the top ten
but you know not the top three
and you take a look at the rest of these
names and
you know they are
of mostly asian and
one of the reasons for that even
canadian solar by the way is an asian
company
one of the reasons for that is that the
the
asian governments did support
the manufacturing and did in fact make
the capital
much less expensive so many of these
companies
were able to establish
lots of manufacturing capacity at
um at you know low
prices so they didn't have to pay as
much for equipment because it was
supported by the government
that doesn't mean that they didn't work
hard as well i mean to get the techno
establish the technology
to you know install the equipment to get
a process running on it to get
high yields to get the supply chain to
work all of that
certainly takes its um that it takes a
lot of effort
and and you know in my view that i think
that
the asian governments were a little bit
more
they were more clear in the strategy
that they wanted to take
towards renewables and particularly
solar in this case
and they made a commitment and they
they've you know
people were able to easily access that
that funding in that money
and it led to um to you know the picture
that you see here
so um but as i mentioned so so what
happened is that
there became you know hundreds of solar
cell manufacturers because as we talked
about earlier the device itself is
really not that complicated
and there was a lot of um
innovation that had been done on the
equipment side
and it was actually done mostly out of
europe
and in the us where the equipment
platforms
became such they could generate higher
volume
at similar price points and so now if
you had
a tool you could you could easily um you
know pump out 50 megawatts
whereas earlier a couple years before
you could only do 25
so so the capital
if you had the have you had the money to
spend and buy the equipment
you could pretty easily generate solar
cells
um and there was a you know ready market
for them
um through a lot of the um the power
plant and the incentives that various
countries have put in place
and so there was a ready market and you
know if you
can if you put the effort into it you'll
certainly
be able to um make panels and
and with so many players doing that the
prices dropped
which is actually exactly what the solar
industry always wanted to have happen
if you talk to people who've been in the
industry for a long time they're always
waiting and waiting
for solar to be cheap enough because
what we want is for solar to be
um to reach grid parity and be not
a decision for you know a
you know a emotional or moral
decision but a financial decision to say
hey i've got an alternative which is
just as good let me just go with that
so that's always been the drive and that
requires solar to be cheap
so this big flux of activity that
happened in asia actually drove those
prices cheaper
and so today we've got a really
broad scale deployment of solar energy
which is actually very exciting to
to see but just challenging to be a part
of if you're not a big player
and you know this kind of gives you a
another view of that but
you know about half the manufacturing is
in china and about
less than five percent of the us i think
this is even like a worse figure as time
goes on
um however and then you know why are
these things
important and now we get into more of
the you know industry aspects of it too
but
you know if you have a manufacturing job
um
in my last few slides here speak about
manufacturing since
that's kind of what's on our mind um of
late
if you have a manufacturing job in your
area you will one dollar
that is goes towards manufacturing
actually
returns you know 1.4
in the overall sector because
you you know your supply chain and you
know labor and all of those other things
that go along with it
are enhanced considerably whereas the
same thing in you know
other areas like retail it doesn't
generate as
much overall
economic growth as
does manufacturing and so this is also
kind of
a consistent with what many of us have
experienced over the last few decades as
manufacturing has reduced in the u.s and
increased in other parts of the world
there was a question on the solar supply
chain
and and where that's at so i wanted to
include a slide
um about that this is the overall from
equipment down to
production and if you see here there's a
lot of u.s
companies that that have an important
role to play
and i've taken some of this material
from
a talk i gave at intersolar which
compared u.s and china manufacturing
so it's focused more on u.s rather than
just europe but you'll see
most of the equipment suppliers are
actually european
and an american you have very few
asians some but few equipment
manufacturers
materials you know dupont and these guys
said
and then the definitely the silicon guys
they had a
they've had a um
a very substantial growth in their um
businesses that have supplied materials
to the pv industry
and so you know it doesn't matter where
that growth is happening these guys are
the preferred suppliers um they will
benefit and they
did and they have from a manufacturing
perspective
um there's uh there's few of us
um and if you look at where the
substantial
growth in manufacturing capacity has
been first solar is actually
expanded in asia and most of these other
companies
will as well most likely
so um i know
probably manufacturing is not on your
mind so much but as
a as you kind of look at
the future and you kind of see
what different roles r d and
plays and how it feeds back into this
support cycle of making goods now i'm
not talking about software but we're
talking about hardware where you're
actually producing
um you know sellable goods
the cornerstones in my view and
certainly we see this in the solar
industry
is equipment r d and supply chain
and all those lead to you know
a high productivity and
excellence in manufacturing but it's a
feedback cycle
so the more you learn about what is
working in manufacturing
the more you can adjust your equipment
the better you can
spec the materials that you're using
right so there's actually a
information cycle in here that if you
break this
you and you know you only do this you
actually are going to
not be able to take advantage of the
learning that happens
and the people who are doing this will
start doing this
and they will learn
more and more about what needs to be
done
and so it's really important to kind of
see this picture and and
make sure where your value is and um
and you know ideally have it such that
there's an enhancement to
to the entire feedback cycle um
the full feedback cycle
and i just took this uh cartoon from
apparently there was a very famous
meeting that happened between obama and
um
and steve jobs and you know the question
was
can we get some of these jobs back and
the answer was you know
once they're once they leave it's really
hard to get them back and it's
basically in my view because of this
because once
you break this cycle um
you're it's it's hard to recreate it
so we have to be opportunistic about
what we do
um my last two slides here um
you know there's a lot of things in the
valley that come and go
there's a lot of technologies nanotubes
actually are
around but you know the level of impact
that they had
isn't what we expected it to be there's
a lot of things that become popular and
then less popular etc
in my view solar is not a fad it did go
through and it is going through its
you know swings and cycles but
overall energy is a huge need and demand
and solar is a technology
that fits that demand and as time goes
on
um there's various different capacities
in which it's used so on rooftops as i
mentioned
in um in power plants we haven't even
you know the portable doesn't even make
this list yet because it's such an
emerging market
but if you you know with a little bit of
imagination i think we can imagine
we can see that that will also add
considerably to
um to society hopefully favorably
and overall solar is still a very very
small
fraction of what the overall energy
mixes in the u.s
but but i think most of us believe in
hope
and desire it to be a larger fraction as
time goes on
okay thank you
how do you see organic solar cells as a
competitor
yeah so organic solar cells um
there's uh there's a fair amount of work
being done on them in universities
and um i guess the um
and they they also have the benefit of
being flexible um and the idea is that
they can be very cheap because it's very
cheap materials that you start off with
i think the thing to watch out for when
you are looking to develop that
and deploy it into industry is that many
of the other things you have to do
are still similar cost so you have to
still put metal on it that metal is
going to cost you the same as
if you were to put it onto silicon or on
gallium arsenide
you still have to encapsulate it and
glass likely or put some sort of a
hermetic ceiling
on it if it's flexible or rigid that's
going to cost you the same
so the key is going to be the efficiency
and so if you can
and i know that's what people are kind
of working on but where you start off
from is
is pretty low right now right single
digit efficiencies
so if those and i know that there's
predictions people have that it can also
be 40
so if you can get beyond i mean at least
reach you know double digit efficiencies
um i think then it starts becoming
you know a more substantial player but
otherwise i think
you know in general it's kind of
interesting that there's a lot of
materials that if you shine light on
them boom they will generate power so
it's really a matter of like selecting
which ones
are the um you know will
generate the most amount of power and so
efficiency there plays a
you know role i am of course an
efficiency person you know having worked
at sunpower and now working in alta
devices
and you know there's i i have more of an
efficiency bias towards
the industry i mean everybody knows it's
better but some people feel
that there's other ways of reducing cost
so certainly having opv
is you start off with very cheap
material so that's a plus point
um the efficiency part is the challenge
oh and also one other thing i think low
light is actually quite good
with opv so that's
will play a role yeah take into
consideration about
temperature changes so outside of
california where it's
sunny but where you might have like 100
degrees for a high and then negative
five for degrees for a high
and you have hail and other things yeah
excellent question and actually
you know a lot of um of uh
what is talked about is dollars per watt
but really what should be talked about
is dollar
dollars per kilowatt hour produced and
that's where temperature
and you know you're integrating over
your over the whole year and location
comes into play a lot more
otherwise most of these things that
people actually quote are under
standard testing conditions which
basically don't occur in the real world
so so the industry's getting smarter and
smarter about
you know comparing these fundamentally
the crystalline silicon has a worse
temperature coefficient so if you are on
a hot roof
and you're i say 20 panel you will
not generate as much power as if you
were a thin film panel
at the same efficiencies so the technolo
and so all thin film has better
temperature coefficients
so the the drop in if everybody is worse
at higher temperatures because your you
know the mobility of your
um of your electrons is not as good as
if it's cooler
but some materials suffer more than
others so
thin film there's less of a drop in
efficiency as temperature increases
again gallium arsenide turns out has a
much better temperature coefficient
than silicon so we also are better at
higher temperatures
than if you compare with um with crystal
and silicon
protection from weather events like
storms hail or blizzards
right so um so you know qualification
and certification is a big deal in this
industry reliability
um because it is you know used in
building materials
um and um and so there is a
certification that involves fire and
hail
and moisture all of that that people
have to pass
and in order to get the qualification to
have a 25-year
warranty etc and that's again because
they're mostly used in you know building
type applications
unlike what we what i was talking about
with these
you know more emerging markets and
the um the there is established tests
um for those um that and you know the
panels have actually been around for
several decades and so people recognize
that
the the if the materials you of
construction that you use are
are um appropriate you won't have
warranty problems
most of it actually comes from the glass
and the aluminum frames so glass is a
material that's already proven
to being um you know resilient to nature
and to the um to the elements
and so that's one of the reasons glass
is used it's also cheap
yes um what's the price comparison per
kilowatt hour for gallium arsenide
versus silicon and also
what is sort of the capacity like the
maximum capacity you can produce that
um like how rare are gallium and
arsenide are compared to silicon which
is
completely abundant um so definitely
silicon is much more
um you know readily available um on
planet earth
um but gallium is actually a byproduct
of aluminum mining
and so it's also you know there there's
a lot of gallium that's produced um
and when we do our calculations for how
many
you know gigawatts and terawatts we
would produce until we start
affecting global supply it's a lot we
get into the terra watt region but
that's partially because we're
only using a micron of the material
we're not actually using
full wafers and and
so supply is not something that's a
problem and actually it turns out you
know cell phones
your lasers all of these have gallium
arsenides so from a
um you know a material toxicity
perspective also
it's already um you know in many of the
commercial devices that people
use already um so you know
it sounds a little bit more you know
toxic but it really is not as long as
it's maintained together in a
crystalline form
prices um so the um
as i mentioned gallium comes out of
aluminum mining which is pretty cheap
um when we look at our overall cost of
manufacturing
we can reach the same 50 cents a watt
type targets that
silicon can reach but it would be at
scale
and the driver for that is more really
the equipment scaling rather than the
materials
so there's already been a benefit that
you know the led market has grown
substantially over the last
few years as well right so that has
actually you know there's been more
gallium mining that has occurred because
of that
and so there's already an industry that
supports
larger volume of production of the base
materials
yes some uh the importance of
manufacturing and the equipment so
do you know what are the active research
or development that are happening
in this aspect in manufacturing and
equipment for
solar cells okay so like the companies
or the type of
technologies generals yeah
um so so you know kind of a
uh you know one example would be
that um the
there's a wet etch process that you have
to do um in order to texture
the surface of the crystal and silicon
solar cells
and and you know there's a company
in the black forest in germany that
makes this tool in fact
maybe i can tell you a little bit about
what their story has been so um you know
this was the
the um the german woodworking industry
um in the black forest um was
was well known for the tools that they
used to do the woodwork
okay though as time went on those
companies that would make the tooling
started making tooling for the pcb
industry and for the semiconductor
industry so there were
two they were equipment makers or tool
makers and but they kind of
you know as the as industrialization
changed to different industries they
actually followed that but they were
smaller scale
right and so when solar kind of came up
um
people looked around and said hey okay
who will potentially do this kind of
strange
slightly custom thing that i need to
have done and these companies
you know popped up and so we you know go
to them and say hey can you change this
you know wet edge tool to do this and
this and you know they're very capable
equipment manufacturers and so they
would do this so this is not applied
materials and lamb
and you know tell and all these
established semiconductor
equipment makers they're basically small
town you know
equipment suppliers but they're willing
to do something that's
different and custom and takes more
technology
um so then the industry started booming
and they said okay we make two and
they're like okay we can make two and
then
can you make 10 and then can you make
100 and so they're like oh my goodness
so
those if you look at those companies
well
the boom has happened well well you hear
a lot about the
chinese solar manufacturers there's
another side parallel story for the
equipment manufacturers in asia
that have you know gone from small like
literally a
farmer founded this company and two now
they're like the major suppliers with
half a billion dollar
of revenue as they're selling these
equipment into china
and around the world but um so so what
some of
the things that they've done is that
they used to make smaller tools that
would have maybe four lanes of wafers
etching at the same time and they said
hey we can actually get
rollers to have this be
10 lanes at the same time now you know
it's harder to keep the wafers in line
as you they have to go through this
entire you know long edge process
but with the appropriate technology with
the appropriate machining with the
precision
with you know knowing the right coatings
to put onto your gears to
make sure that they last long et cetera
et cetera all those things have led to
innovation that now they have like
amazing yield
because you can break silicon wafers
very easily there's only they're only
200 microns or less thick
so they you know you can transport them
along
this this wet edge tool and and you know
99.99 of the wafers come out
um with um with a high uh
you know passing the process and
previously that would be
much less so that's an example of kind
of
where innovation and technology has
played an important role
for the industry so actually there was
if you kind of follow the equipment
story applied materials did actually get
into
the solar equipment manufacturing and
they came in from the thin film angle
because they they were depositing thin
films anyway
so they thought oh i've got some big
equipment that deposits
um thin film for my flat panel display
uh tools
why don't i use those same tools for the
solar industry
so so that's good and they you know work
for a while but the challenge is that
the solar price point for your end
product is much lower
than it is for semiconductors or for
flat panels and so your equipment needs
to also
be you know simplified and the
manufacturing
and has to be consistent with those
costs
so the solar manufacturers for equipment
don't actually make the same amount of
profits
that that standard semiconductor guys do
but they make it up in volume
okay good all right well thank you very
much i think we're right on
time here yeah